I was going to ask if for you to find
that performance did you do a lot of
research and if so it must been a
harrowing experience doing that research
well sure I have one friend that I
focused on who is a friend of mine from
Central Falls Rhode Island who lost a
child to murder in the 80s 1981 I think
and she was seven years old and she was
taken from her grandmother's backyard
one o'clock in the afternoon she's
playing with her friends and then all of
a sudden she was gone
and it was you know well publicized
search until they finally found her body
and I spoke to her a lot because I
thought to myself you can give the kind
of watered filtered down version of it
that had kind of a glorious ending you
know or you could be completely
realistic and really it was like time it
Stood Still it's like she said I can be
sitting and I could be completely fine
in the next second I am absolutely right
back there it is a living nightmare that
has no end and so I just tried to pick
her brain as to what the everyday was
like but I thought it was really
interesting when she said there is no
relief I think the only thing she said
was I go to church a lot
I like candles I pray I believe in God I
believe in a higher power
I have other children left that I love
and grandchildren and that was it this
film feels very different than the ones
that get a lot of mainstream released
support these days and that's very
satisfying as well yeah I mean you know
people always ask me that about even the
television show that I'm doing they say
what makes it different and I always say
well me my presence makes it different
you know it is sure I think that you
know sometimes you go on automatic when
you watch cinema and you forget that not
everybody listen
I loved Brady Bunch when I was growing
up to me that was the ideal family show
until I grew up and realized that does
not necessarily represent all families
you know now we know better we know
better so we have to do better and yeah
so me and Jennifer Lopez being it that's
what makes it different it's great you
know what a primary thing we were trying
to get across or we were talking about
was you know giving a voice to a certain
kind of mothers that hadn't been paid
attention to so that was that was the
primary thing and that's why I was just
very grateful that miss Davis and mr.
Lopez agreed to give them that voice so
biblical I was curious like with even
other name sounds like Lilith I was
influenced by Lilith Eve also the name
Lila has some meaning and in Eastern
religion about the nature of God on
earth and so yeah there were there's a
certain spiritual level that you know
there's the surface one and then I think
there's another layer about the nature
of of Justice in the world and you know
I think it's there for people if they
see it so I think that in terms of what
Pat's talking about the canvass of the
movie like the overall impact of the
film I think for folks who are used to
very specific styles or genres it's
confusing because it is fantastical in
one aspect because it's a part of our
psyche it's the alter ego it's this this
person that does not exist but coupled
with how we painted it how we portrayed
it like realistically I mean in Biola
performance and viola and I had many
many discussions about the realism of of
this state of mind of this being of this
person and what she's going through and
her drive to really be authentic which
always excited me because there was
going to be a super - natural or a
surreal you know element to it that was
gonna be an interesting twist and I
think you know it's not a hundred
percent popcorn film where she's a 100
per character Zyliss committed to
killing and destroying everybody you
don't mean and then just walking away I
mean the monkey on the one's back so to
speak with her character at the very end
where she's singing that song it's
haunting you know it's another thing
viola was like I really want to make
sure that at the end of the story
there's a form of closure but it's not
over it's like what you just talked
about it just that that pain goes
somewhere you put it somewhere you deal
with it but it's not like it's gone so
she drives off in the sunset so to speak
but it's actually kind of a haunting
sunset so yeah absolutely and there's a
responsibility when telling stories like
this to be authentic to the victim
experience into the victims family
experience and we don't really see that
very often in film so it's you know the
scenes where you're in the hospital the
scenes where you're you're grappling
with the memories and stuff the often we
don't see that in movies we see the rage
in this where the kind of Charles
Bronson approach yeah with the woman
story you really had to add new nuances
or else it would just feel like a dress
you know yeah because Charles Bronson
can get a gun and just shoot people and
people like yeah that's right you know
when a woman does it it's like oh yeah
but can't you be a little nice about it
you know and um so I mean I mean there
is an unapologetic aspect of it and what
I liked about it if
if I can be so bold to say is it wasn't
like after every killing she explored
any kind of regret that the exploration
really was how can I get over my pain
not how can I get over the fact that I
killed people too you know and I kind of
like that with girls in it I do it's
it's there's something very liberating
about it at the end of the day